liberalism is really hard to to
reconcile with
motherhood and so to the extent that
feminism is derived from liberalism as
the sort of ground of political
movement if if your priority is the
freedom of the individual and if your
unit of analysis is the individual how
in Earth do you de with motherhood
because babies aren't really
individuals because they can't survive
for even an hour without the devoted
care of at least one adult
and certainly mothers when they have
newborns aren't really individuals
either certainly in the early
days mother and baby are a unit and if
you and if your understanding of society
is of individuals sort of like atoms
just occasionally bumping into one
another but basically operating solo
what do you do about the mother baby
diet it just doesn't really make sense